最近撮った面白い動画何だろう最近撮った面白い動画を見せましょう
あとは考えですか
あっはぁまた徹夜なんてがなだけだったんで使用のショットガンで打ったら入った借り
ました
和美社長ですああ
いやまだあるぞまだあるぞ事務所で編集しているとミックさんですね
横からみるとやはりこの
伝わりますかん
[音楽]
んびんだしたくないこれ男子か
電撃はてるんだよなにこれ便利技が走るやれよ
4つが腹につけるやつ
聞いますあレッツの顔は
ああああああ
バッハ
んだ
あっあぁああああ
楽しい毎日を過ごしております外れ社長です質問等なぁ
明日やります新しい段階に入ってくれる気がなかったんでちょっともうしばらくシック
首相待ちくださいできればできれば明日だしたいと思っていますので今日は軽くいき
ますよ
今回なんですかね
って郊外のですけどもう twitter なるでくらいいただきました私とができる
と誰ですか
あるまでメントスコーラよりもマーブル直行らがやばいと4なのでいつかやってほしい
です自分でやるのは環境的に難しいのであお菓子会見してからでお願いします
安心しなさい食べなければいいんです後で誰かに食わせ夜明けでメントスコーラ並んで
マーブルチョココーラっていうのは凄いと言う
母を聞けてきたのね今回やっていこうと思いますもうメントスコーラなんてどれだけ
やってないことが私から遠ざかってで全然やってないんですけど
[音楽]
もう全然大丈夫もうお菓子の10枠にはまったく通じませんもうを稼いだした精神力が
すごすぎて全然大丈夫です
9コーラですねうん
[音楽]
安心してくれ俺も今年はノブことはないからてで今回こちらのマーブルチョコとコーラ
これを合わせたらなんかメントスコーラですごいみたいな噂を聞いたこの人も漫画で見
たからわかんないんですけど
ただどうかってのは基礎わからないで今が実際に確かめてみようと思います
ツアーといっかいやろう1回もメントスコーラ方好きでやりマーブルチョコって面倒
作りか一緒なんですよひょっとしたらその
コーティングの成分的にはマーブルチョコの方が強いのかもしれないそれによって
メントスコーナーですごい爆発力になっているとしたらもう
かも知れませんからね今てはいけませんよ一発ですからねいやては今といけませんだ
もうすぐ行きますからな使っちゃってくるこの感じがたまらないぜ
釣れ
って
まあ
[拍手]
振って迷うなぁ
なあ時間差でずっとなってるんですけどすごいマーブルチョコがここでうろちょろし
てるんですよ時間され
なんかずっと小浦免とさほど半田はないんですけどもずっと弱くずっと反応する感じ
ですずっと中でマーブルチョコが劣ってるみたいな米すごい
これたぶん
コーラじゃなくても反応する気がするんですよね
ダイレクトに全部入れちゃおう
[音楽]
さあどうなるダーツ不都合やがってきたですごいんだけどこちらがすごいよ
いちごいっぱいちょっと待ってこっちの方が凄いよイベント激しいこっち凄い凄い連結
すごいねー
浮きそうで浮かない
あぶねー回だけでマーブルチョコやってみたんですけども
ua というかまぁコーラ面倒とはちょっと違う方向ってクリスすごかったでここら
へんでマーブルチョコすごい浮いたり沈んだり
踊っていたので
[音楽]
幸せな気分になりましたあー
も女性両県マーブルチョコ補正と
いいえ
me
あっ